[Music]
hi i'm ria and here are my edible gift
ideas for this holiday season
[Music]
sometimes it's overwhelming to the
holiday shopping and could cost a lot of
money
but if you make edible gifts by yourself
it's fun personal and less expensive
these cookies can be used as ornaments
and you can also eat them
you will make simple cut out sugar
cookies and roll it out to rectangular
shapes
cut them out with cookie cutters usually
when you are making cut out cookies you
will remove the scrubs but for this you
don't need to
keep them scraps and use them as pieces
of your ornaments
i think those irregular shapes look cool
and very unique and also it looks like a
puzzle pieces
make sure to cut out little holes so you
can hang them when you bake them make
sure to separate them so they don't
stick together
[Music]
to finish i decorate them with royal
icing but you can give them without it
if you want to keep them on the tree for
a longer period of time
put them in a plastic bag
[Music]
these cookies can be the perfect
low-cost but super personal holiday gift
for your friends and family
[Music]
these cookies that look like snowballs
go by many names such as mexican
weddings cookies and russian tea cakes
they are perfect as a winter holiday
gift
crushed nuts and powdered sugar gives
them a very soft and delicate texture it
will melt in your mouth
i use the walnuts for this recipe but
you can use almonds or pecans the dough
will be a little crumbly but once you
start shaping it it's easy to shape into
ball shapes
you don't want to make it too brown so
bake it at the low temperature
325 fahrenheit is usually good setting
for these cookies
make sure to coat them with powdered
sugar while they are still hot so the
sugar sticks better since these cookies
are very fragile i recommend putting
them in a jar or a box when giving them
as a gift
i used glass jars and added a christmas
ornament and a little toy so it feels
more festive if you are beginner baker i
recommend you to make candid nuts
because it's super easy and you will
only need a few ingredients basically
you will coat your favorite nuts with
egg whites sugar and pinch of salt you
can also add spices like cinnamon if
you'd like bake them in the oven but
make sure to mix them every 10 minutes
so the nuts are well coated with
frosting you can eat them as is but they
are also perfect for salad and cake
toppings they also go well with cheese
plates
they are crunchy and delicious give it a
try
[Music]
so i made this video for the final
season of game of thrones watch party
but you can stencil anything you like
for example a holiday motif or the
receiver's favorite things say superhero
logo or astrological sign be creative
i'm using my go-to sugar cookie dough
here but you can use your favorite sugar
cookie dough when you're making this
recipe
if you want to use my recipe you can see
recipe details in the video description
make sure to chew the dough before you
use it so it holds shape
i'm not great at making stencils so i
asked my friend nifty producer and my
work wife tommy to help me once you cut
out stencils make sure to hold the
cutout paper really tight when you are
dubbing cocoa powder
so cocoa powder doesn't get underneath
the paper it could ruin the pattern you
just created if it does when you bake it
make sure to bake it at 350 fahrenheit
and rotate halfway through you don't
want to make it too brown
so you can highlight the cool design of
the cookie
i think this is a fun and creative way
of making personalized cookies
this is also a super easy edible gift
idea for you
it's a no-bake dessert you just melt
dark chocolate and mix it in with your
favorite cookies or cereal
i think you can even make in a dorm room
if you have a microwave
when you're using double boiler make
sure the water doesn't get into the
chocolate so it won't sit
if you are melting chocolate in a
microwave and it has seeds add a little
bit of coconut oil as an easy fix
once it's set cut them into bite sides
and rub them it's a very easy yet
delicious edible gift
when my husband and i were newly wrapped
we had a small budget to buy gifts for
all of our family members and friends
so we decided to bake cookies for them
instead
we baked different kinds of cookies and
put them in a jar or box
and gave them as a gift we did it for a
few years and it has become our
tradition
now i enjoy baking cookies during
holiday season what are your holiday
traditions
[Music]
so
you